governments today are grappling with the
change brought about by technology the
shift in demands of citizens
expectations and service standards has
created a new Need for governments
worldwide to seek new definitions of
design and delivery GX Now tracks key
governments across the world in the hope
of finding answers to what governments
of Tomorrow will look like how they will
deliver excellence and why experiences
may be the key to unlocking the value
behind government citizen engagements GX
is an idea born out of the United Arab
Emirates created to fulfill the promise
of government Service delivery and
changing it to an experience the model
is now slowly evolving to become a
template that can be used globally to
create government Service delivery
excellence in GX now you will hear a
collection of global perspectives coming
from both the public as well as from the
private sector the opinions of guests in
this documentary are to a huge extent
based on their experiences of working
with governments and being at pivotal
positions where governments and the
private sector interface looking at some
of the biggest opportunities ahead and
also some of the challenges governments
must face in the next few years GX now
is the story of dreaming big of
Excellence of changing perceptions and
of creating a better future for
government services worldwide
my name is Ian Khan thank you for
joining me on this journey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you look at the current state of the
government experience domain there
really isn't a standard everybody across
the world is doing things differently
and there's an impact of different
Industries on government experience in
some parts of the world government
experiences dictated by the retail
sector and we make a comparison between
retail services and government services
what is happening within governments is
also an after effect of how other
Industries are serving their clients
their clientele and their client base
governments across the world are trying
to adapt to different things and in
times of political instability changing
governments the priorities of
governments are changing
foreign
let's talk to Jonathan reichenthal I
spoke to Jonathan about his experiences
and the challenges that he's seen
governments have across the world now
Jonathan works with governments from
Asia to the Middle East to the Americas
and in Europe as well and he knows the
pulse of governments and the challenges
that governments are facing Jonathan is
a big advocate of change as a professor
as an educator and as a business owner
his thoughts are critical in helping us
understand where we should go and what
governments should do in order to
progress
[Music]
one of the things I'm observing as I
have the privilege to visit many
different governments and cities around
the world it's number one a recognition
that communities have much higher
expectations of Service delivery today
and so if you're a Community member you
know you're used to using consumer apps
on your smartphone or going to a website
and then you use a government service
and it's not nearly as good or perhaps
it's not even digital the sense is now
that this is becoming you know no longer
acceptable we have to step the game up
one of the participants of the GX
program is Jane Wiseman I spoke to Gene
about what are the challenges of
government and what do governments in
the Western World face especially in the
United States and what are her
experiences of government service and
government service excellence half of
Americans can't tell the difference
between a Google search result and a
Google ad we need better data literacy
so that we can be
Savvy about what are reliable sources of
fact
Tim Unwin is UNESCO chair in ICT and
he's also a professor at the Royal
Holloway University in London Tim brings
a lot of experience when it comes to
working internationally at a Grassroots
level and what's the state of government
experience and services in Europe
in many countries of the world people
don't trust their governments and I'm
seeking from my experience in Africa
they often are willing to trust the
private sector rather than governments
so I think there's some really
interesting things around that but if
people don't trust governments they're
not going to be willing to engage with
those service Provisions unless of
course the government makes it essential
that they do so through their digital
systems I remember you know a few years
ago many countries were saying we're
going to go digital by default but that
automatically excludes those who aren't
digital people with disabilities elderly
people they are going to be marginalized
by any move to government services
unless alternative mechanisms are put in
place so actually you're going to need
to provide service centers where people
can come to so digital by default will
marginalize
Marlo's pomp was the head of blockchain
and the head of AI Partnerships for the
government of Netherlands is an amazing
resource he has so much knowledge and
information because she works with other
governments from across the world as
head of blockchain and some very
critical programs by the government of
Netherlands Marlow's knows what
challenges of governments are when it
comes to technology implementation
thank you
in the Netherlands the government has
selected five key Technologies like
blockchain artificial intelligence Big
Data cyber security and 5D and we will
invest in this technology more in the
coming years to improve these Services
we try to build a human-centric
applications it also means that we have
a lot of focus on the risk of these new
technologies for example the government
already uses a lot of AI in in their
services but of course there's also the
risk of discrimination so that's why the
ministry of justice has launched a
guideline for all the governmental
Services who are using new technologies
like artificial intelligence
I also spoke with the head of
e-residency for the Estonian government
both weather has been working for the
government Estonia for many years and he
brings a lot of experience when it comes
to working with startups working with
International bodies International
governments and he shared some really
critical insights when it comes to
government experience and what does the
e-residency program hold and why is it
such a great example of creating
government experience that is seamless
and it adds a tremendous amount of value
for any country of any size
the difference between government
services in EU in Asia in U.S is is very
large and I think EU has some
similarities here but again looking at
conservative countries who do not have
maybe that amount of trust for the
government or government keeping their
data safe which is also very important
then these Services cannot develop
looking at countries like India who's
rolling out an identity program as well
but 1.3 billion compared to our
estonia's 1.3 million is a bit of
another challenge
Estonia is one of the biggest examples
that is used when it's about government
using technology and creating efficiency
in what governments do I spoke with the
CIO of the government of Estonia seems
secret we talk about what his challenges
have been and how he sees the government
experience changing from an Estonian
perspective
our main approach is to make Services
invisible as much as we can let's not
focus on interactions let's focusing on
you know delivering a value rather so a
value is for example that we ensure
compliance that's why we asked the
entrepreneur for some sort of report
even if we ask it online and my point
here is being that if we think of it
from that perspective we often see that
we don't need to design for those
individual interactions and services we
can get rid of many online services
literally by automating things away and
so iFly the philosophy aside what it
practically means that we're trying to
understand at least kill different
online services we built up by adding
more automation adding more sort of data
integration a bit more small data
analytics and stuff like that one of the
first approaches on that parents of
newborn babies don't have to apply
forbearance and benefit it's
automatically being sort of grounded for
them we are building it up for companies
that if companies Will consent and agree
the government to have access to their
financial records or you know let's say
data that is digital anyways then we
won't ever bother them with a report
word not for tax not for employment but
for statistics not for annual reports so
forth all these things the companies can
now do online why do we bother them with
an extra step if you have data it's done
[Music]
there are definitely outliers and
there's definitely countries that are
making a solid effort in the right
direction to fully understand the
commitment that the government of the
United Arab Emirates has provided to the
government experience initiative and to
set forth a precedent in government
Service delivery I spoke with someone
who's leading these efforts at the prime
minister's office in the UAE Muhammad
in the past the focus was more on how we
built the services in terms of processes
in terms of transforming services from
being manual to becoming automatic and
paperless however the customers today
look
for services that are more towards their
experience and other parts of services
in the world that they are familiar with
and they would like to see government
services being delivered in a similar
way or even better
[Music]
Elaine bijani is the CEO of the merged
Alpha Team group in the UAE the majdal
for team group is one of the largest
groups managing retail in the Middle
East Elaine shared a lot of critical
insights how the retail sector affects
government how governments can learn
from the retail sector Allen also works
for the world economic forum and
different governments and bodies in
creating start leadership ideas and
initiatives that affect governments
worldwide before the Industrial
Revolution is a reality within it and I
would say it's very important that the
rate of change on the inside be at least
equal if not if not faster than the rate
of change on the outside it's also
allowing us to be able to deal with some
of the endemic issues that we couldn't
deal with before technology today
presents that capability to do that and
is becoming more ubiquitous more
affordable and more simple to use it's
now on us our generation of leaders to
make sure that we turn this into the
opportunity that it actually is to make
sure that we can drive sustainable
economic growth employment creation job
creation and we can drive a better
integration of our Societies in the
world
[Music]
is the CEO of an AI based company
focused within the insurance industry
but he brings a lot of critical insight
to the idea of GX over the past maybe
five to eight years customers are no
longer willing to tolerate delays or
lack of transparency or not knowing
what's the next step or being mistreated
for that matter historically the economy
was more like product driven in the 70s
and then you get into the 80s and the
90s and now it's more moving towards
like a relationship economy we live in
the experience economy and I think this
is something that you will see more and
more and more when you think about the
effort that we're putting together
across the board private sector public
sector and how we're all trying to put
everything around the customer make sure
that the customer is actually the
epicenter and how can we actually from a
government standpoint contribute to
their quality of life contribute to
their well-being take away all the
uncertainties that come with it and give
them the ability to focus on on what
they would like to focus on what they
love most and what they like best which
is a service that's one curated around
them two that is there when they need it
and actually think about what does the
customer slash citizen need and not what
does the government need for very long
time governments have been focused on
actually designing services or they're
implementing those designs in a way that
suits the governments from different
perspectives and I think what we're
seeing here is actually a total reversal
[Music]
I spoke with government in Azerbaijan
and the head of the Assan service center
the Assad service centers have
completely changed the idea of Service
delivery by bringing together different
vendors and as many as 300 plus services
at one place it has radically changed
how government is delivering services at
a service center level traditional ways
are not suitable anymore to provide our
services and to get satisfaction level
but also we know that it's not only
about Technologies it's also about
organizational structures it's about
human resources and we are trying to
build suitable environment in order to
provide our services effectively and
efficient at our citizens
where the government has placed an
incredible emphasis on that is the
recognition that everyone is different
and a tremendous experience is often not
something that is entirely frictionless
like booking a train ticket it's not
that difficult to say what is the
station you need to go to what time were
you leaving from and how many passengers
are there that's a very automated
process that has almost no variation but
when you're trying to change your name
and actually the options that you're
going for are not available but when
you're trying to consume healthcare
services and you have
two children who are naturally born one
is adopted these are the type of unique
situations that actually when
organizations are able to deal with that
effectively that's what makes people
feel really good about it because it
makes it feel like we actually
understand that there aren't very
personalized requirements that that
citizens have if you sit at home how is
your feeling about the services you get
from the government are you worried
about missing out or forgetting about
paying your bills your utility is built
or are you comfortable because you know
that it will automatically be processed
through your digital assistant that kind
of level and that kind of experience is
what we're seeking we are a customer
does not need to worry everything runs
in the background on their behalf
consuming government services anywhere
in the world is normally met with the
thought of bureaucracy and lots of
paperwork I think what's different here
is that there has been a incredible
focus on making sure the pain and the
friction that normally is involved with
the yearly renewal of services has been
taken away now whether that is having
your car renewed which is almost
entirely our digital transaction now and
whether that is your national ID or
whether that's just paying for your
parking through your mobile phone
everything is now interlinked and what
is very neat is there is a single Portal
app where you can then go on and whether
it's hospitals or funeral parlors or
government service centers all of that
information is now housed in one place
foreign
[Music]
I saw a survey that three quarters of
CEOs think that customer experience is
very important to their business
but there's no such survey in government
I don't know how many government leaders
think the customer experience is top
priority but I'll tell you there are 10
million government employees and it's
not top priority for everyone
let's say you have to go to a place you
have to go to a physical Place what's
the experience like when you get there
is it is it crowded and chaotic do you
know what to do do you get good customer
service do you talk to people that are
well informed and if they have
difficulty themselves getting you the
information do they have access to
information tools to help you as a
community member I think I see
governments now beginning to think about
the entire life cycle
of a process for example getting a copy
of your birth certificate when you want
to submit a request for a permit which
is such a common city or government
activity it shouldn't be as hard as it
is today people don't look forward to
that and the experience should be better
you should be able to and increasingly
request a permit online without having
to go to a place
and take a number and wait and spend
half your day in a government office in
the United Arab Emirates we focus on
customer experience from their live
instances so for example if the customer
has a newborn baby we look at that as an
a point of life where they need
government services
about having a new baby therefore we
started looking at it from a bundling
perspective so instead of a customer
looking at which government entities or
or government service centers they
should visit they just know what bundle
they want I'll give you an example of
one of the services that we have it's
called mayak which means congratulations
on you your newborn and it bonded more
than seven Services into one step and
more than five payments into one payment
and to get everything related to this
newborn within three hours now using the
splendor
we are now moving from a Non-Stop shop
model to non-stop shop model in Assam
service centers we are providing
reactive services to our citizens but
now we started launch new project which
is called mygov my government project
and it's about providing proactive
services to our citizens for that we are
very widely using data in order to
predict expectations of our citizens and
in-house by the government we are trying
to involve the companies to this process
as well
foreign
as a result of really rapidly changing
world what is changing is also citizen
expectations citizens today expect a
different level of service at a
government level the expectations are a
combination of what they're seeing in
the private sector in the retail sector
in the healthcare sector and a
combination of this is leading to the
overall citizen need if you will for
service Excellence today's citizens you
and I we all use smartphones and
Technology to make decisions to access
services and it's very common just to
expect that every service should be
available on a cell phone should be
available on a mobile device but not all
governments have been able to translate
services from a service center to online
most so-called governance agendas are
actually about governments providing
services to people through technology so
we can see government websites where you
can access forms to fill in passports or
licenses or pay tax that is a really
interesting change of management
structure in the old days governments
had lots of civil servants lots of
people working for them to do the
paperwork now the effort and load has
been transferred back down to the
citizens it's like in the old days when
you might attend a meeting somebody
would send you all the paperwork in
advance you didn't have to do anything
you just read the paperwork and took it
to the meeting now you're sent the files
digitally by email or another online
system or even you're expected to go
online to download those forms yourself
then read them then perhaps print them
off because you might need to take them
to the meeting so that is a shift of
Labor from governments to Citizens or
from organizations to employees I hate
having to log on to three or four
different sites every day to get
information whereas it could easily just
be sent to me in another form the
standard rhetoric is is of course that
it makes it much easier for governments
and citizens to interact on key things
that they need to do and that
undoubtedly have its advantages it's
it's very easy now to submit a passport
application online or your tax forms
online second
mode and I'll use the example of our own
government digital service there are
many great things about gov dot UK
however if you want to find out anything
from the government website about a
government department or what it does
it's almost impossible
and I think that is an indication of
this difference between government
service provision and the relationship
between governments and citizens and the
openness and the transparency around
that
today I think
citizens are co-creators in a government
experience There's an opportunity for
each of us to be partners and help get
stuff done a greater openness in you
know more Progressive cities and more
tools for collaboration are allowing
community members in particular to
participate in everything from decision
making to design sessions even
development of solutions there's some
very interesting experiments being done
with Community co-funding identifying
funds from public sector and private
sector to get projects done that has
been difficult to get moving because of
the Reliance purely on public funds if a
government makes available data and a
Community member says hey I could build
a solution using that data wow what
that's a great relationship that's a
great partnership we have software
Engineers now who can step up create
interesting Solutions or try to make
sense of data and serve up the analytics
that helps decision makers make better
decisions that's a relationship we've
never had the tools to be able to do
before a good democratic government
experience is is not a spectator sport
it's a it's a it's something you
participate in
state of Washington is one of my
favorite performance driven
organizations there's something called
results Washington every single metric
about state government is available
online drill Downs to get greater detail
and when the governor hosts a results
meeting the public is invited it's
streamed live online
but they also include a customer or two
or three in every single meeting so if
it's about Youth Development there are
actually youth there giving feedback to
the government about how the services
are improving where they need more
Improvement so that's a great example at
the state level and right now 90 of our
federal government websites are
collecting customer feedback and trying
to iteratively improve my takeaway is
that it's really interesting what's
happening in the world today the amount
of data that is generated on a daily
basis is just mind-boggling yet you talk
to a lot of the Enterprise you talk to
government you talk to a private sector
you talk to large corporates and they
will tell you that they have poor data
issues with quality there are gaps in
the data there's a problem there's a lot
of Legacy systems and data that's out
there that's quite difficult to mine and
bring to the surface when you're
building something Greenfield it's much
more simple to do that from from A to Z
but the truth is a lot of government
departments have huge Legacy of
information systems that they're using
and traditional processes so the
difficulties trying to stitch those
together in a format that the customer
doesn't feel any bumps it's like having
a shopping trolley being pushed across a
railway track very bumpy experience and
what you're trying to do is take all of
those knots out of the experience
[Music]
in all services you need a form of
identity but it's identity it sounds
like there's only one identity and I
expect you I have several identities
which you can use so I will use another
identity to log in in my for example in
my Google accounts then I will use for a
governmental service for example I hope
these digital identities several
identities are owned by me and are
controlled by me the state of Indiana
recently created a single sign-on so
that I can get my Park permit renew my
driver's license you know certifications
any government activity that I'm doing
with the state is all under one ID so
that I don't have to continually
re-enter my information so that's
wonderful sort of One-Stop Shop but you
know we're still a long way from being
able to integrate from the Federal to
the state to the local with a single
identity and
annably worth being careful about this
because with a single identity in
government comes risk you know could it
be hacked when it's done by the private
sector
government doesn't have the control and
can't police it in the way that might be
necessary so for example in the U.S we
have for the ability to travel the
Transportation Security Administration
is responsible for issuing TSA pre-check
you know so that they vet me and then I
can go in an express lane well there's
also a private sector entity that's
doing that what is the fundamental role
of government should it be the
government that says who can get on a
plane
and is safe to travel and who isn't if
you let the government have all of your
identity what might they do with it I
often liken this to what happened uh in
Rwanda where the use of older digital
Technologies radio for example enabled
many parts of the genocide there to
happen more efficiently so if a
government knows everybody's identity
and where they live and everything about
them what can they do with that
information for migrants it's very often
issues around whether qualifications for
example gained in one country can be
compatible with those gained in another
country imagine if everybody had a
digital identity that they could take
with them so that if you're moving from
Kenya to South Africa or from Haiti to
Brazil actually you can take your
identity with you I think that raises
really exciting possibilities not only
for migrants but also for governments if
we could get Global agreements around
what the parameters and what the
credential officials in digital identity
meant that could be really beneficial
[Music]
so it won't be one technology which will
solve the digital identity topic it will
be a combination and at this moment we
really try to figure out how can we
combine a digital identity with privacy
preserving Technologies like serial
knowledge proofs or multi-party
computation I think this is a really
interesting area to explore at an
international level
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we believe in Estonia that digital
identity is the backbone of everything
every person should have an identity
matched to them physically and digitally
so every Estonian communicates with the
government using their digital identity
meaning they do everything from bank
statements taxes to registering the the
childbirth using the digital identity
and we really can't imagine our life any
other way it's been actually for us as
Estonian government a Learning Journey
to get to have experience in Focus I'll
be very honest here I think we've been
very techy and engineer-led throughout
our sort of beginning years especially
in a sense that seeing locate how much
better how much more efficient we can be
if we functionally build things up and
you know for example put services online
whatever the experience now we've really
come to the point that to get to the
next levels obviously experience has to
be at the Forefront because otherwise we
don't have people as using it and and so
it goes off course way Beyond just
issues of nice neat design of an online
environment our core focus is is how do
we make the process the working of
government
into the best experience and in other
case for us just to you know look
forward I mean it's about how do we
simplify it radically because the best
experience at least as far as a student
is concerned if there's none if that
happens for me as an Estonian it's very
hard to give advice on physical service
centers because for us digital Journey
has meant getting rid of them largely
there is the tech support that has a
physical stand and perhaps the post but
otherwise if we talk about governmental
Services they are 99 online if you can't
get access to digital in whatever means
because you don't have connectivity you
don't have electricity you're going to
be further marginalized by the delivery
of Digital Services classic example is
around the notion of smart cities I
often say just by saying the word smart
cities actually implies Villages are
fairly dumb so one of the main
challenges is very much that you can't
deliver say what you can in a small
densely populated area that has full
connectivity that's why why it's so
important to have access in the first
instance not all our citizens are
technologically illiterate that's why we
need us on service centers in all parts
of our country also we have mobile buses
these buses are
specially equipped with different
Technologies we send that process to the
remote areas where we don't have Assan
service centers in order to serve our
citizens and also we have volunteers the
human factor within the government
experience is a primary factor from all
perspectives I would say so if it is
from a customer perspective or from a
government employee perspective even the
employees who work on delivering
government services we looked at their
happiness level we looked at how they
understand what customers want therefore
we have conducted a series of trainings
it's a customer happiness training where
we look at the front line employees who
provide the services we train them on
how to conduct business in a manner that
will make the customer happier and also
at the same time we looked at the
supervisors of these government service
centers which we call in the United Arab
Emirates the customer happiness centers
and we train them on how to supervise a
team of customer happiness officers I'm
not in favor of absolutely 100
abolishing every government service
physically because we see that some
regions for Estonia this is the kind of
only form of communication that some of
these people actually have and they
enjoy these forms of communication they
enjoy going to the post office but in
terms of City Life the terms of actually
going to to the tax office and waiting
three hours to fill in a stack of paper
that should be eliminated absolutely
[Music]
the way to shape government services is
really clear we need across the board a
template of Excellence we need something
that can be easily adapted easily
deployed for example if a country has a
model of Excellence is that model able
to be replicated across different groups
across different departments and
Ministries that's exactly what is needed
the GX program in the United Arab
Emirates is an excellent example of that
government service Excellence is a top
priority for the government of the UAE
things such as tweeting about the
rankings of government service centers
is not very uncommon in the UAE and this
is how leadership runs the country GX
was created with the vision in mind to
drive the attention of people working on
Services regardless to the type of
customers or the Persona of the customer
we need to focus on the experience of
that customer now now who is part of the
GX everyone so it could be private
sector it could be investors startups
entrepreneurs who could be part of the
GX platform has multiple aspects to it
we have the government services Forum
that brings leaders from around the
world around the table to discuss
government services we have the GX
Online platform that shares knowledge
base how governments around the world
improve customer experience we have also
the GX stocks so the GX talks also focus
on getting total leaders from different
backgrounds to talk about experience of
customers whether it is digital
experience or it is also the physical
experience or even experience that has
no touch point so for example if you sit
at home how is your feeling about the
services you get from the government are
you worried about missing out or
forgetting about paying your bills your
utilities bills or are you comfortable
because you know that it will
automatically
be processed the UAE is an impressive
Nation they've got the advantage of
being fast and Nimble and agile right
now in the way that they go after
initiatives plus they've got leadership
that's truly vested and believes in
going digital and adopting the fourth
Industrial Revolution I think these
ingredients when you put them together
gives you a very unique environment
because of the platform that's been
created by investing in this futuristic
thinking it's not just their vision and
their talk but they're building things
and doing things I've I've been able to
experience these things firsthand in
Dubai
for example their concept around the
future police station it's a beautiful
experience people feel safe and a lot of
it is done by use of digital
Technologies assistance from the right
resources via a video conference which I
thought was was incredible you see a lot
of experimentation and prototyping you
see very bold projects everything from
Smart Dubai right through to the
paperless Society thus making the cost
of government the last data to be more
accurate all the benefits we would
expect one of the big ones the
environmental positive side of not
having all this paper they're doing the
things they're demonstrating they're
experimenting they're helping other
communities and cities and governments
around the world see what's possible
sharing these insights with the world
and wanting to create things like the GX
Forum which becomes a global platform to
say hey you know what there's different
ways to have a government experience
we've got to be able to create channels
that takes these best practices the
stuff that goes well and maybe even the
learnings of the stuff that doesn't go
so well all the time and share it with
governments in in every corner of the
world so I think the thing that's
important about it being an
international conversation and frankly
being an in-person conversation because
we're all busy if we just try to get
together by phone or webinar we're going
to get distracted but when you plant
yourself physically with other people
you make the kinds of connections that
last and that allow us to keep advancing
the ball to continue to refine our
thinking and to challenge each other
that sense of almost like a healthy peer
competition like oh I'm gonna have to
have something to say when I get back
together with this group you know what
have I done what do I bring to the table
so I think that's a a real value that we
can see in this group it's really
necessary to have experiments within
your own organization because otherwise
it's too complicated to have these
discussions with other partners who
develop services so you must test and
explore a little bit within your own
organization you must train your
employee is there are hardly any
projects where you don't have to
collaborate so it's really important to
learn how you can build firm coalitions
and what kind of agreements do you need
the legal issues around these
collaborations the governance models of
course it's very difficult to implement
ideas as it is because every country has
own culture as on tradition as an
environment and you can see how the
challenge in that environment and how
they solve that problems during the
implementation process initiatives like
this can often tend to be wanting to
come up with the best Global solution
but these ideas revolving relationships
in citizens and states is evolving
technology is evolving so a little bit
more I think self-critique and not
always positive about some of the
activities that have because technology
can be used for good and it can be used
for bad and it's how we how we mediate
those in the interests of citizens for
me citizens are actually more important
than governments governments should
serve their citizens
[Music]
we have learned from e-residents
experiences to try to put yourself in
the shoes of the user because we see
quite often that that's what government
officials are lacking so they sit in
their silos and they don't talk to the
users they don't understand the needs of
the users in the age of smartphones and
all of the private sector services that
we actually consume all the time we
can't expect our governments to lag
behind we believe in Estonia that
governments can never compete with
private companies and they should but
governments are the ones who have to
offer government services so it's time
to actually go together with the trends
what's happening in the world
foreign
star rating program is the first of its
kind that assesses government service
centers as if they are hotels so just
like when you walk into a hotel and you
see that this hotel is a five-star hotel
and you understand what experience
you're going to be getting from a
five-star hotel the same similar concept
has been applied to government service
centers
guided us to make United Arab Emirates
government as efficient as Banks and
works 24 7 like airports since this
program has been launched we have
realized the fruits of this program by
seeing customer happiness centers
improve significantly over the past
eight years the abdomen transparometer
ranks the UE very high the highest is
not the second highest in the region and
one of the highest in the world I think
with 84 trust the UE has always designed
its government services and looked at
Government Services as actually an
enabler society today the UAE is looking
forward I say I want to do even more and
even better I want to be even more
customer-centric I want to make sure
that my government services are actually
not just the best in the world but the
most satisfactory in the world for the
people that use them and actually how
can I enhance their life how can I
actually add value to their lives and
this is something that we're seeing
happening day in day out this culture of
transparency that's coming across more
and more in the UAE in order to be the
best in the world we have also to hold
up the mirror and this is something that
you're seeing happening and I think the
government is leading by example
thank you
[Music]
the future of the GX program by the
prime minister's office in the United
Arab Emirates is strong it's something
that's tangible it's something that can
be developed and adopted by every
government service program in the world
but it needs work it needs work because
implementation of these things is
complex you need stakeholders to agree
on these things you need to get the
buy-in from people who run governments
and those are some of the challenges
that other governments might face when
adopting this program we live in an era
of disruption fast changing expectations
in order to make the world a better
place we will have to play the game in a
different way whether it's GX or any
other program at a government service
level it needs the commitment of the
leadership of these countries of these
apartments and groups so this is an
amazing time there is so much potential
and we need two things we need number
one to listen and number two to act and
when you put those two things together
it makes a huge difference
so in the U.S the Veterans
Administration which serves former
members of the military who are now back
in the country they started a customer
satisfaction survey and it turns out
people who responded to the survey and
gave feedback were four times more
satisfied with government than others
now don't know yet whether some of that
is sample bias that those who decided to
answer the survey were more satisfied
but to me it also says that there is
power in just asking for feedback when
you engage the public they become more
excited the city of Santa Monica
California has a well-being index they
have decided that the purpose of that
city is to support the well-being of its
people one of the things they've done is
social media sentiment mining so they
can tell which neighborhoods are showing
through the publicly available
information on Facebook and Twitter what
neighborhoods are under stress what
neighborhoods are worried about money
and how can the city really do something
about that we now have drug treatment in
jails because the people who were coming
out of jails were 120 times more likely
than the average person to die of a drug
overdose so now we can do interventions
in our jails because the data approach
allowed us to Target when community
members got to participate and
help the government choose where the
money goes when the people made the
decisions there was more investment in
health more investment in education and
some of those early cities that employed
this showed lower incidence of infant
mortality you know five years ten years
from now I think we're going to have a
much higher level of trust in government
because with all of these new ways of
engaging the public there are untapped
ideas and resources and potential for
really making government just far better
than it's ever been we are planning to
implement personalized services for our
citizens from any country from any place
and without any barriers and to be
accessible and available for that we
need also to implement new technologies
AI machine learning deep learning and
other Technologies now we are
implementing shirts cloud-based document
flow system and it helps us to reduce
the cost for building test services and
to optimize that processes
[Music]
the governments of the future are going
to be focused more on purpose and less
on Services services are going to be
done artificial intelligence machine
learning is going to take care of most
of the services being delivered we're
going to be focusing more on thinking
about our future on how we can magnify
Life as a nation as a community the
governments will have much more time
capabilities and much higher quotient
when it gets to livability when it gets
to the future of government is going to
be about a lot of the problems that we
know today a lot of the topics that you
are trying to solve for today are not
going to be there in 10 years time we
are all going to be augmented in our
capabilities as a human being we're
going to be able to do more for less but
also we're going to be able to actually
focus on where we actually make the
biggest difference and drive the biggest
impact not in terms of the small things
that happen around us in terms of
enriching life on Earth and how we can
actually be a continuous edge of change
and progress
[Music]
I believe that AI is definitely going to
be the next cycle of major Revolution
and technology and what we're going to
be able to do with it are a lot of
products and services that were not
possible in the past but it's not my
belief that the AI algorithm is going to
become sentient one day and wake up and
figure out that humans need to be
eradicated let's be more pragmatic and
more realistic and let's not worry about
the Sci-Fi part the part of AI that's
really exciting are most helpful for
corporate user or the corporate worker
the first one is this concept of digital
twin and the concept of the digital twin
is that it's an assistant that's working
side by side with the human to be able
to improve the quality of the type of
work that they're doing by relegating
all the mundane manual tasks over to the
AI and the automation so that the human
is actually focusing on the things that
they should be focusing on not filing
the papers not thumping through things
and trying to index you know a thousand
pages that should be done by machines
and the digital twin should be providing
this workflow automation for the human
to become more effective and more
efficient
a lot of services May will be Global
Services and then on top of that or
beside that you will have a local flavor
but but I see in for example with the
blockchain projects the registration of
diplomas now it's done by countries by
themselves I expect this will be a
global Service we bring people from all
these coalitions and all these
communities together to work on these
challenges which are mainly Global
challenges and I think at this moment
the first step to bring these experts
together they need each other for
example the blockchain experts they need
more and more data and so they need the
experts from the Big Data are working
group with also the data experts from
the artificial intelligence working
group so the next step is to build
broader collaborations worldwide and I
hope the Netherlands can be the gateway
to Europe for many services the future
of government services should be
something that happens without the
customer asking for it we know what the
customers want why not deliver it to
them why not go to the customer instead
of having a customer to us we want to
relate it more to the digital experience
that customers they have with online
shopping where they get recommendations
on what to buy based on their previous
searches on the time of the year we want
to be something similar to that and
maybe even more proactive we are aware
that the way education is going to be
delivered is going to change we are
aware that Healthcare is going to change
all of these Services need to be
integrated in a way and in a manner that
makes it seamless to the customer seems
to the investor of the future we have
taken most of our services online
already but now it's the matter of
actually measuring the quality of these
Services how do they function what could
be improved what's the journey behind it
you can do most of the stuff online but
we still have lots of Relic in the
process in Estonia when we opened up our
services to non-citizens using
e-residency that means that we might
might have some Estonian documents from
time to time pop up to the foreigners in
our systems that's something that needs
to be worked on we're working towards
the perception of having these seamless
background Services once you are born we
already know your name we know your
birth date we know quite a lot of things
about you same for medicine for example
we're looking at some of the ways where
we can predict what illnesses you might
have or or what's genetic about you and
and like we've been very pragmatic in a
sense to say look let's figure out how
to solve this organizationally legally
have proper safeguards in place
technologically as well so this sort of
approach to fixing problems and sort of
solving them in a very engineer way even
through design is is one part of it and
the other part we have benefited from
the fact that obviously we are a small
country in that sense and the Size
Doesn't Matter really for the point of
view how many people that live but just
the I would say that as a small country
we have very lean governance in terms of
how decisions are made and I think if
oftentimes if countries are asking me
okay so what makes a stone a bit more
Nimble because decision making is faster
and not too many levels of government to
consult and so forth so so that's what
has allowed us to go quite a bit way and
I've seen in bigger countries too if
somehow decision making gets streamlined
of course in Democratic context then
you're able to make leaps because Tech
moves fast you have to be able to move
faster long as well
[Music]
what will really change the world is
when enlightened Progressive governments
are able to easily connect with
enlightened active citizens
I mean because that's a potent Force you
bring those two things together and we
can do some really amazing things to
sort of tension that exists between
communities and governments because you
know communities have great expectations
the governments try hard but they they
struggle to to meet those expectations
in a digital world you can deliver more
consistently and getting access to
information and data when they need it
creating more of a seamless Channel
between when the data is created by
government or collected by government
and the desire to be able to access that
simply because we want to know what
government's collecting on us but also
to be able to make better decisions and
to develop Solutions
there will be a much greater degree of
Automation in the future and this will
be both in the digital world through the
use of artificial intelligence but also
through Robotics and so we will have
questions about what does that mean to
The Human Experience what does that mean
to jobs what does that mean to to the
personal connection we have between an
individual and a provider so we'll see
all the positives of Automation and
artificial intelligence we also got to
be conscious of what that means
ultimately to us as humans we have to
decide what we want to do about that
there'll be more change in the next 10
to 20 years than in the last hundred
years when it comes to government
experience it's going to be a remarkable
time
all the different methodologies
available today including the GX program
are amazing they can change how citizens
are served they can change how citizens
you and I access services at a
government level in the country of our
choice I really believe governments need
to look at GX as a program that can
bring a new wave of energy that can
bring efficiency and accountability in
their governments
the United Nations predicts that global
population will reach 9.8 billion people
by 2050. this means more expectations
from governments to serve citizens
better and create better experiences
this means a more complex world with new
stakeholders new challenges and new
speeds of response in 2020 Humanity
battled A new challenge the covid-19
pandemic many governments struggle to
cope with the pandemic and yet many
succeeded Beyond expectations in
managing controlling and eliminating the
threat of the pandemic one thing all
responsive and successful governments
did was their ability to respond fast to
engage with citizens and to focus on
success while looking to the Future it
is these governments thinkers leaders
and Trailblazers that are in the process
of creating a better world
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you believe that there is a social
contract between the governed and the
government then the thing that
governments need to keep in mind when
they provide services is what people
really want to get from that
relationship
[Applause]
sometimes the solution that will work in
one place won't work in another so being
very curious about the histories and
cultures in which you're working in
order to match up the services with the
particular residents or citizens that
they're serving I think is a real
leadership skill
making it an outside in approach to
Services delivery as opposed to inside
the government out is a change of of a
paradigm of how government traditionally
develops and delivers policy and then
thinks about Service delivery
challenges that governments face are no
longer technical in nature those we
figured out how to solve the problems
that are facing governments today are
more around
Wicked problems such as how do we solve
homelessness
how do we improve food delivery to
people how do we improve people's
quality of life we started with public
policy focusing a lot on markets and
market failure and how government had to
solve problems of market failure I think
that's still an important thing but I
think we have to go beyond that now and
understand that equity and Justice are
really important factors that we have to
take into account and figure out how we
can devise public policies that make
sure that we're being Equitable and
we're being fair and just there are
places that are excelling in doing
Digital Services but I have yet to see a
government that then harvests the data
on the back end for customer insight for
Predictive Analytics you know geospatial
analysis and really optimizing
performance just because you have a
large large data set does not
necessarily mean it can help you in any
way if you can't unlock value or
information from that raw data and so
the way I think about how government can
play a role is to really focus on
information that's valuable for
constituents for policy makers for
Citizens for residents for for visitors
use that information to all be on the
same page for what success looks like
and how to assess whether or not you've
hit criteria that you've set and then
ultimately learn and iterate from there
today customers have expectations that
are drastically different than what
governments offer today as services and
we should bridge the gap I worry that in
a downturn we're going to have to be
even more efficient in the way we serve
and with the expansion of Digital
Services we need to think about how we
do old-fashioned services in a new way
one thing that we do within a city can
impact traffic which can impact housing
which can impact the migration of people
we have to consider everything within
systems and within the the greater
mechanisms of this and not just on
individual decisions make sure you have
the right business cases and the right
governance in place that you can't
innovate if it takes a year to approve a
business case to do a new service
[Music]
[Music]
the one thing that government needs to
focus on primarily is really trying to
understand Community it's at the very
micro level of a city and using
technology is one way to be able to do
that but also being able to embed
themselves within communities deeply to
understand the greatest challenges that
people face are facing and then being
able to use that data in a way that can
actually affect change this next
Generation cares more about issues like
the planet issues about housing equality
than previous generations but I think we
have to make government attractive to
them
[Music]